[Applause]
very
thank you thank you thank you
great I appreciate I know it's exciting
it's our last show of the year and it
was not an easy knot I love you too
because it was not an easy year to get
through we did it together I couldn't
have done it without you the viewer or
you the homeless I couldn't well I mean
you're watching this impeachment thing
okay today was better than when's the
first day was a little rough today we
had Murray Ivanovich did you see that
she was pretty good the former
ambassador for the Ukraine she testified
how trump smeared and smeared her and
she felt threatened by him and then
while she was testifying to this Trump
[ __ ] tweeted smears and threats while
she was testifying to smears and threats
which is witness intimidation which is
an impeachable offense that he committed
during his impeachment hearing
do you see why I need a vacation yet
trumpet this is what he tweeted he said
everywhere every Ivanovich winter turned
bad she started off in Somalia how'd
that go
I've seen men blame some stupid [ __ ] on
women but Somalia you know you know she
couldn't fix Charlie Sheen's love life
he's attacking her for surfing in a one
most dangerous spots in the world most
dangerous spot he's ever been in there's
a sand trap you know I see I think too
many analogies on TV to Watergate
impeachment hearings this is very
different
Watergate Nixon said I am NOT a crook
Trump says I'm a crook so what that's a
very different situation we're in
they're there they have no real defense
on the facts their defense is stop
picking on the poor guy poor Donald
Trump he was born rich he doesn't pay
taxes he dodged the draft he got to be
President in an election he lost what is
he gonna catch a break
and to distract this from all this today
Trump released a transcript of a
different perfect call to the Ukrainian
president and in this new call he
doesn't commit a single crime that's his
defense what about all the times I
called someone and didn't commit a crime
[Applause]
this would be like Bill Clinton having
the defense I'd like to enter an
evidence this photograph of Monica
Lewinsky not blowing me anybody watching
this [ __ ] okay are you because the the
have you seen the Republican impeachment
star Jim Jordan of Ohio he always looks
like a guy who's about to get into a bar
fight and tell somebody hold my jacket
I believe the Republicans keep him in a
cage they feed him Red Bull and Crystal
Method they shoot his ass with steroids
and then they unleash him on the hearing
room Jim Jordan he's a former wrestling
coach who the players say knew that the
team doctor was sexually abusing a lot
of the players and he did nothing about
it now to be fair to Jim Jordan he is
not accused of abusing any of the
players himself he just stood by well
did nothing while horrible things
happened so good practice for the
hearing
this is all alleged but you know a
million people say the doctor the
abusing doctor's name was Strauss and
people kept telling Jim Jordan that this
doctor like goes into the shower and
looks at the players and is masturbating
and Jordan apparently says yeah that
Strauss funny comeback except except
when you have come on your back
it's a free upwards knock TV what are
you so uptight about and also this blows
my mind Jim Jordan
representative Jim Board is the second
wrestling coach turned Republican
Congressmen who has had a sex scandal
having to do with the wrestling children
remember Dennis Hastert anybody remember
Dennis I said okay he went to prison for
paying hush money to someone who very
credibly said apparently because he paid
hush money but he was also a creepy
wrestling coach I mean the Democrats
have had their scandals sexually of
course Anthony Weiner comes to mind but
this like that the Democrats had two
guys who texted pictures of their dick
next to a baby oh I guess you don't
remember that about Anthony Weiner good
night ladies and gentlemen that nobody
remembers that Anthony Weiner touched in
a picture [ __ ] you on to other news
about Republicans boy let's stick to
hitting them Roger stone went
there he is there he is as the penguin
that's right Roger stone you know him as
Trump's albino assassin and sort of the
he was drums political Svengali for 30
years and he is the latest convicted
felon to join the Trump crime family in
prison and this besides being an
admitted dirty trickster Roger stone you
know about Roger stone kinky in fact
when he heard the verdict he was already
in handcuffs he was he was guilty of
perjury intimidation and witness
tampering and one of the witnesses that
stone threatened God to work with
company in New York 40 years ago Randy
credit Co got into politics I guess he
regrets it because Roger stone
threatened him threatened him that he
would take away his dog
I think this sums up the whole year
Trump's keep calling this a witch-hunt
and yet it's Roger stone who literally
says I'll get you and your little dog
[Applause]
you